Beim Rettungsschirm verwenden wir schlussendlich ganz einfache Leinen, meistens auch Dyneema, die aber eher dick sind und auch viel, viel weniger dicht gewoben sind.
Weil gerade dort ist es wichtig, wie vorhin schon angesprochen, dass wenn wir eine Öffnung hätten, dass es nicht eine riesige Belastung gibt, sondern das ganze System sich auch dehnen darf.
Es ist absolut sekundär, dass das Formstabil, Längsstabil ist, dass es sich dehnen darf, setzt sich auch dehnen, hat eigentlich diese positiven Eigenschaften.
Beim Rettungsschirm gibt es ganz verschiedene Modelle. Hier sehen wir schnell momentan das in der Mitte, das ist eine sogenannte Kreuzkappe.
Das ist so ein bisschen das, was aktuell auf dem Markt ist und sehr gut funktioniert.
Dann links unten, die rote, ist eher ein älteres Modell, das ist eine Rundkappe, die momentan ein bisschen verdrängt wird von der Kreuzkappe, aus einem einfachen Grund, weil die Kreuzkappe sehr pendelstabil ist.
Und bei der Rundkappe haben wir eher mal ein Pendel drin.
Und dann gibt es auch noch verschiedene andere Formen, das ist jetzt noch so ein Dreieck, wo man ein bisschen Fahrt aufnehmen kann und mit dem kann man steuern.
Das ist allerdings mehr für Profis vorbehalten, weil man doch nach dem Treppenzug auch noch aktiv den Rettungsschirm steuern muss.
Für einen Schüler, für jemanden, der anfängt zu fliegen, macht es absolut Sinn, eine Kreuzkappe, mit der kommst du runter und alles ist gut und du musst dich nicht noch für ein Rettungssystem konzentrieren.
Wenn man einen Rettungsschirm, ein Rettungsgerät zieht, dann kommt man ungefähr mit 5,5 Metern pro Sekunde runter, das entspricht ungefähr, wie wir hier auf dem Bild sehen, einer Höhe von 1,5 Metern.
Jetzt haben wir aber bei 1,5 Metern Sprung nicht nichts an, sondern wir haben die ganze Gleitschirmausrüstung, das Gurtzeug, nämlich unsere Kleider, Helme etc. an, das heisst, es ist schnell mal viel Gewicht und dann sind vielleicht die 1,5 Meter plötzlich eher schwierig oder auch doch mit einem kleinen Impuls.
In der Realität sieht es nämlich so aus, dass wir eher von 2,3 Metern runter springen, weil die Rettungsschirme werden getestet, indem sie von einem Helikopter oder von der Brücke ausgelöst werden, aber immer ohne Gleitschirm.
Also sprich, da ist ein Gewicht dran, es wird ausgelöst, es fällt runter, that's it.
In der Realität haben wir ja meistens den Gleitschirm noch mit uns verbunden und der Gleitschirm kann auch ein bisschen stören.
Das heisst, das ganze System will vielleicht eher mal ein wenig schaukeln und beeinflusst dann die Sinkgeschwindigkeiten definitiv und es kann dann auch schnell mal ein wenig höher sein.
Allerdings ist es wirklich so gebaut, dass wenn man auf die Füsse kommt, dass es eigentlich ein Impact ist, den man gut verkraften kann.
Am allerwichtigsten einfach, dass man wirklich auf die Beine kommt und nicht das Gefühl hat, man sitze irgendwie ab und komme auf den Protektor des Gurtzeuges.
Der Protektor ist nie so gut wie unsere Beine.
Ein besserer Protektor ist unser Bein.
Darum die absolute Priorität nach einem Retterwurf muss sein, auf die Beine zu landen.
Wenn wir schon bei den Protektoren sind, da gibt es ganz verschiedene Gurtzüge, die Protektoren haben.
Und auf der linken Seite haben wir jetzt so eines, das einen Schaumstoff verbaut hat.
Das hat natürlich den Vorteil, der Schutz ist von Anfang an da.
Hat einfach den grossen Nachteil, es ist relativ schwer und vor allem das Volumen, wenn man es einpackt, ist recht gross.
Da gibt es andere Formen.
Da haben wir gesagt, wir wollen das Volumen relativ klein haben und haben dann so Airbags gemacht,
die sich allerdings erst füllen, wenn wir in der Luft sind, wenn der Fahrtwind reinbläst.
Und am Start, wo es eigentlich sehr wichtig war mit dem Schutz, haben wir keinen Schutz.
Da gibt es auch Unterformen, wo z.B. ein Gurtzeug direkt zu einem Rucksack gemacht werden kann.
Das nennt man den Wendegurtzug.
Das Wendegurtzug hat natürlich den Vorteil, dass du keinen extra Rucksack brauchst, also Gewichtsersparnis.
Aber wir machen das Material relativ leicht.
Wir machen das Material relativ fest beanspruchen.
Und wir machen die Reissverschlüsse auch sehr viel auf und zu.
Das heisst, es gibt eher mal einen Schaden.
Und der Protektor wird vielleicht so eingepackt, dass er relativ komprimiert drin ist und entlüftet sich.
Danach entfaltet er sich nicht mehr so schön nach mehrmaligem Gebrauch.
Um das Ganze ein wenig zu lösen, hat ein Hersteller ein sehr gutes System entwickelt,
welches man hier im rechten Bild sieht.
Er hat ein Gurtzeug entwickelt, welches man aufblasen lässt.
Bereits vor dem Start.
Also händisch oder mit so einem Blossack.
Damit die Luft drinnen ist.
Man macht zu und hat bereits ab dem Start einen super Protektor.
Und wenn man ihn nicht braucht, lässt man die Luft ab.
Man hat ein ganz geringes Volumen und ganz wenig Gewicht dabei.
Es gibt natürlich auch die Extremform, die Leute wählen zum zum Beispiel Heikonflyen.
Die sagen, sie verzichten komplett auf den Schutz.
Das sehen wir im linken Ecken oben.
Wo dann wirklich nur das Basic ist.
Also ein Gurt.
Wo man bequem drin sitzt.
Der hat keinen Schutz.
Und man muss den Notschirm auch separat aufhängen.
Man kann ihn nicht integriert in ein Gurtzeug hinein.
Eine andere Form sind die Liegengurtzüge.
Es gibt auch mittlerweile einen Riesenmarkt von Licht bis Schwer.
Schlussendlich der grosse Vorteil des Liegengurtzüges ist ganz klar,
dass man natürlich aerodynamisch in der Luft liegt.
Das ist eine bessere Vergleichsleistung des Schirms.
Und man ist relativ fest windgeschützt.
Man hat also warm, wenn man lange Flüge macht.
Man hat relativ viel Platz für ein Cockpit.
Man sieht hier oben.
Da ist sogar so ein leichtes Scheibchen vordran.
Wo man natürlich auch Geräte optimal platzieren kann.
Und gute Sicht hat auf die Geräte.
Alle, die so ein wenig Wettkampf fliegen.
Oder eben lange Streckenflüge machen.
Mehrere Stunden in der Luft sind.
Die wählen eigentlich eine Liegengurtzug.
Weil es definitiv für diese Vorteile hat.
Die Nachteile sind halt, dass man ein wenig manövrierumfähig ist.
Weil man nicht ganz aufrecht sitzt.
Das ist ein völlig anderes Gefühl.
Man muss sich auch lernen.
Und man hat nicht den direkten Blick nach oben.
Darum macht es in der Schulung absolut Sinn,
ein Sitzgurtzug zu wählen.
Und dann gibt es wie erklärt in verschiedenen Klassen.
Hier gibt es Heiko-Brei-Gurtzüge.
Hier gibt es Streckengurtzüge.
Die Akrobatik-Piloten, Freestyle-Piloten
haben wieder ein anderes Gurtzug.
Da gibt es ganz verschiedene und gute Gurtzüge auf dem Markt.
Lasst euch auch dort beraten.
Das lohnt sich mal hineinzusitzen.
Und herauszufinden, welches Gurtzug für euch passt.
Den Aufbau des Gleitschirms haben wir schlussendlich
so ganz einfach.
Es geht darum, dass wir ein Drahtgurt haben.
Das sehen wir auch hier,
wo wir schlussendlich aufgehängt sind.
Dann die Handschlaufen,
wo wir schlussendlich drinnen sind.
Hier noch eine kleine Anmerkung.
Wenn ihr die Handschlaufen habt,
haltet sie so.
Wickelt sie so einmal.
Aber geht nie so durch und fliegt sie so.
Weil wenn sie so in der Handschlaufe drin wären
und ihr müsst den Notschirm ziehen,
kann es sein, gerade speziell im Winter,
wenn wir noch Handschuhe haben,
dass wir uns wie Fesseln da nicht rauskämpfen.
Darum eignet euch eine Technik,
mit der ihr jederzeit die Hand sauber rausbringt.
Dann haben wir die Leine,
nämlich die Bremsleine, die ganz hinten
an der Austrittskante des Schirms angemacht ist.
Und danach geht es C-, B- und A-Ebene.
A-Ebene ist die vorderste,
wo man den Schirm schlussendlich brauchen kann,
um beim Start aufzuziehen.
Dann oben zum Segel gehen wir an die Hinterkante,
die an der Austrittskante genannt ist.
Vorne ist Profilnase oder Eintrittskante,
wo die Luft einströmt.
Und dann haben wir das Ober- und Untersegel.
Und im Gleitschirm haben wir auch noch ganz viel Innenleben.
Da haben wir Zellen, Zwischenwände
und wir haben die sogenannten Cross-Spots.
Cross-Spots sind nichts anderes als Löcher
in der Zellwand, die verursachen,
dass die Luft sich gleichmässig im Flügel verteilen kann.
Wie wir einen Gleitschirm schon einmal gesehen haben,
seht ihr, dass er vorne Öffnungen hat
und gegen den Stabilen, gegen den Rand des Gleitschirms,
sind die Öffnungen oftmals zu.
Und dass auch die Luft dort hinein kann,
was den Druck verursacht,
dass der Flügel super schön in der Luft liegt
und offen ist, machen wir die Cross-Spots,
dann findet ein Luftausgleich statt
und das ganze Schirmlicht sieht wunderschön in der Luft gefüllt aus.
Den Traggurt selber haben wir vorher gesehen.
Das sind die Leinenebene.
Wir haben Leinenschlösschen,
die so kleine Schraubkarabiner sind
und wir haben den Beschleuniger.
Darauf sehen wir jetzt einen Fussbeschleuniger,
wo man mit dem Fuss, also zuerst einhängt,
mit dem Gurt verbindet
und den Fuss drücken kann.
Es passiert nichts anderes,
als dass hier die A-Ebene nach oben gezogen wird.
Durch das, was passiert,
wird der Anstellwinkel kleiner,
der Schirm wird schneller.
Der Fussbeschleuniger, wie man hier auf dem Bild sieht,
wird vor allem bei den Soloschirmen verbaut,
weil dort die Piloten wunderbar mit dem Bein strecken können
und die Geschwindigkeit sauber beeinflussen können auf ihrem Schirm.
Wo es weniger gut geht, ist beim Tandemschirm.
Beim Tandemschirm haben wir die Trimmers drauf,
wie wir sie hier sehen,
die man nach hinten lassen kann,
wie besprochen.
Und das kann man natürlich wunderbar von Hand machen
und braucht den Fuss nicht,
weil dort vorne ist ja der Passagier und man hat gar keinen Platz.
Der Vorteil der Trimmer ist natürlich,
wenn man es von Hand einstellen kann,
kann man da auch sehr schön dazusehen.
Der Nachteil ist,
man kann es nicht einfach so schnell wieder lösen.
Da muss man aktiv mit der Hand hochgreifen.
Beim Fussbeschleuniger kann man drücken und loslassen,
geht es von selbst zurück,
ist etwas einfacher zu bedienen.
Trimmer, Trimming, nicht zu verwechseln,
hier reden wir dann von der Leine,
die man trimmen kann.
Jetzt haben wir ja vorhin bei den Leinematerialien gehört,
dass wir hier verschiedene Leinen haben,
die zum Teil ein bisschen schrumpfen,
ein bisschen dehnen
und der Hersteller versucht,
das möglichst zu verhindern,
dass er einen guten Mix macht von den jeweiligen Leinen.
Es gibt es trotzdem,
dass die Leine sich verformt,
respektive eben verlängert oder etwas verkürzt
und das tut man im Check nachmessen.
Und jetzt stellt man fest,
dass die Leinen doch tatsächlich etwas verlängert sind.
Dann kann man z.B. einen Schlauch reinmachen
und so 1-2 cm den Schirm trimmen,
dass er eben wieder wie im Neuzustand fliegt.
Das macht man mit einem Messverfahren im Gleitschirmcheck
und kann so sehr genau herausfinden,
wo ist der Leinensatz ein bisschen verzogen,
wo kann ich etwas korrigieren,
dass der wieder sauber fliegt.
Also, den Schirm kann man auch wie notrimmen,
und so in einen annähernden Neuzustand wieder bringen,
wenn er mal etwas stärker gebraucht ist.
Was für das ganze Material gilt,
das ist egal ob Schirm,
ob Gurtzeug,
ob Leine,
schlussendlich wollen wir lange Spass daran haben.
Darum ist es wichtig,
dass wir auch wissen,
was eigentlich im Material schadet.
Grundsätzlich kann man sagen,
dass die mechanische Belastung sicher eine Belastung ist,
die vermieden werden sollte.
Also dann ziehe ich das Material nicht im Boden hin,
schlussendlich ist Reibung einfach schlecht für alles Material.
Und mit der mechanischen Belastung ist ja gemeint,
wenn man starke Manöver fliegt,
also wo der Schirm stark beansprucht,
mit viel G-Belastung,
dann wird der Schirm sicher auch schneller altern,
als wenn man das nicht macht.
Die UV-Astrahlung spielt eine grosse Rolle,
wenn wir natürlich in der Luft sind,
können wir es nicht vermeiden.
Wo man es aber vermeiden kann,
ist wenn wir das Material am Boden haben,
dass wir es eben auch zusammen packen
und in den Schatten stellen,
damit die UV-Astrahlung...
Die UV-Astrahlung ist etwas,
was man nicht ganz vermeiden könnte,
weil in der Luft ist es natürlich so,
dass es in der Sonne ausgesetzt ist.
Wo man es aber vermeiden könnte,
ist am Boden,
wenn wir gelandet sind,
den Schirm verpacken,
in den Schatten stellen,
damit möglichst wenig Sonne darauf scheint
und so die UV-Stunde möglichst reduziert werden kann
und nur in der Luft ausgesetzt ist.
Nässe ist allgemein ein Thema.
Einerseits bei der Leine ist es nicht gut,
weil es anfängt zu schrumpfen,
wenn sie fest nass sind,
vor allem viel nass sind.
Und der Schirm ist nass nicht ein Problem,
wenn man ihn auch sofort trocknet.
Schlimm ist,
wenn ein Gleitschirm nass ist
und du ihn dann in einen Packsack packst
und dieser Packsack langst du 2-3 Wochen nicht mehr an,
dann ist das für das Material sicher nicht das Beste.
Unbedingt zu vermeiden,
wenn ihr einen nassen Schirm habt,
dann den trocknen,
zuhause ausbreiten
und erst im trockenen Zustand wieder verpacken.
Am allerschlimmsten,
was wir machen können,
ist, wenn wir einen nassen Schirm haben
und dann noch in Temperaturen aussetzen,
mit der Temperatur ist das klassische Beispiel im Auto.
Im Sommer wird es schnell über 30-40 Grad im Auto
und dann haben wir da drinnen wirklich ein bisschen einen Backofen
und das Ganze wirkt auf das Material sehr, sehr schlecht.
Also schaut euch,
ob euer Material trocken ist
und dass es nicht in extremen Temperaturen ausgesetzt ist.
Säure ist etwas,
vielleicht habt ihr mal ein Landeblatt-Souvenir aufgelesen,
nämlich ein Kuhfladen,
ist letztendlich auch etwas,
das den Schirm respektive die Beschichtung angreift,
was aber auch wichtig ist,
dass man es zwar putzt,
mit Wasserlauwarmasse,
aber nicht irgendwie mit Reinigungsmitteln,
weil das Ganze Beschichtung angreift.
Und gerade wenn wir bei der Beschichtung sind,
ein gutes Stichwort,
der Gleitschirm hat ja die Beschichtung darauf,
dass er eben möglichst nicht zu fest auf UV-Strahlen reagiert
und dass er vor allem auch nicht zu fest Luft durchlässt.
Diese Porosität,
weil wenn ein Schirm zu fest Luft durchlässt,
verliert er Leistung,
verliert Geschwindigkeit
und dann will man verhindern,
mit dieser Beschichtung,
dass das passiert.
Die Beschichtung,
die Sie hier sehen,
die Ripstop-Masserung,
die ist natürlich auch unterschiedlich dick,
weil die Feder unterschiedlich dick ist
und die Beschichtung wird wie draufgepackt
und darauf wird eigentlich gesorgt,
dass die Unterschiede der dicken Fäden
ausgeglichen werden,
dass also ein gleichmässiges Tuch wird,
dass es UV-beständig wird,
dass die Luftdurchlässigkeit gut ist
und allgemein auf mechanische Belastung
weniger schnell reagiert.
Ich hoffe,
dieser Vortrag Materialkunde hat euch gefallen,
euch weiterbringt im Lernen
und dass ihr das Fach Materialkult spielt
und einfach an der Briefung bestellt.